a new study published by the British
medical journal has found the number of
people diagnosed with early onset cancer
has risen significantly in the past
three decades it shows a 79 increase in
cancer patients younger than 50 in the
last 30 years cancer of the breast
windpipe bowel and stomach are amongst
the most prevalent the research found
more than a million people age 50 or
Younger die of the disease every year
with that number projected to rise by 21
in 2030. now scientists studied all and
studied data from more than 200
countries involving 29 different types
of cancer let's speak now to Nicholas
Smith she's the senior health
information manager with cancer research
UK and she joins us now from London
great to have you with us how alarm
should we be at these figures are people
actually getting cancer younger or are
we just getting better at spotting it
so that's a very good question and it's
quite a complicated picture and the
evidence does suggest that there is a
small but significant increase in the
rates of cancer at an earlier stage and
Below 50. however the numbers on this
paper do seem more alarming because
they've looked at the number of cases in
those headline figures rather than the
rates at which people are getting cancer
and the number of cases doesn't take
into account population growth so as
populations are growing over the decades
and we are seeing more people as a whole
so more people are being diagnosed with
cancer and that's certainly an important
factor at play here and as you mentioned
we're getting better at detecting it
over the last 30 years globally we are
getting much better at detecting cancer
and also the recording of cancer
globally is significantly better than it
was 30 years ago so that certainly is
playing a role
however we do think that there are
likely other factors at play so genetics
and also risk factors so earlier
exposure to risk factors
um is a particular worry for some of
these cancer types
um where we are seeing cancers that
could be prevented that people are
experiencing at an earlier age than they
may have otherwise and when you talk
about risk factors you're talking about
smoking exposure to Sun
eating certain types of foods we've
known about these risk factors for a
very long time why do you think people
still indulge in these behaviors to such
a level that it does keep giving us
cancer
so we are seeing
um things like smoking overweight and
obesity uh alcohol consumption
um diet as you mentioned what people are
eating and the study found that in the
west
um linked to Western diets probably is a
factor at play there we are seeing more
cases of cancer
um so there is something important there
for people to take away to think about
how they might be able to make healthier
changes
um unfortunately it isn't necessarily
that easy and the world around us does
have a big impact on on the choices that
we feel are available to us and you know
the advertising that we're exposed to
the laws in in our country
um there it's food that we're exposed to
in our day-to-day life
um yeah it does all play a part in in
the options that are available to us as
as individuals and
um there is a important thing around
awareness and people being able to make
make those choices once they have the
information available
um but the world around us doesn't
necessarily make easy no it doesn't and
what's the prognosis for these people
who are the younger people who are
finding this early onset cancer
so the study looked at cancers between
the age of 14 and 49 and between that
those age ranges that is very it could
look very different in terms of
someone's cancer experience and most of
the people in the study um who had
cancer were in their 40s and we know
that the occurrence of cancer increases
as we get older because the
um cells the changes it can develop in
our cells the mutations in our DNA they
can build up over time and that's why
normally most cancers are experienced at
older ages
um but the most important thing when
we're looking at cancer prognosis is
trying to catch it at an early stage so
if you are experiencing any symptoms
anything that's unusual for you
something that just doesn't feel right
then going to see your GP and going to
see your doctor
and and telling them everything
everything that's been going on being
persistent if those those changes don't
go away
um if something's not normal for you you
know your body best so so make sure
you're getting it checked out and then
benefit is it's not likely to be cancer
but if it is picking it up at an early
stage you're more likely to be treated
successfully Nicholas Smith that's great
advice thank you very much for taking
the time to give it 12 years on altazira
thank you